lion dancing dates back to the tang
dynasty in china
i was really meant to war off the evil
spirits and welcome the good ones
i am a 20-something year old millennial
but i still hold this piece of tradition
[Music]
grab three rings and make three lines i
was born and raised in chinatown
we do have a lot of the chinese
traditions that they've come over and
carried on and passed on to us
lion dancing is really important to
chinatown because it is a traditional
sport it's something that a lot of
people do come out and they celebrate
around chinese new year
typically includes at least two people
per set in a line you'll have somebody
who plays the line head and then
somebody will play the tail
when you first come in you walk through
the door you can't just pick up a line
head
it takes about a year for you to be able
to work your way up to that level kung
fu is the foundation of lion dance their
stances and their leg work is extremely
important
we're having you train in your footwork
and your stances making sure that you're
strong enough to physically hold
yourself through a routine but also a
line head because the line head is heavy
it's typically anywhere between 15 to 30
pounds
[Music]
typically
we teach different routines for each of
the lines just because you never know
which one you're going to play
you can see us line dancing in the
streets any time where there is a
community event we'll usually partake in
them
in chinatown a lot of people are
familiar with line dancing and they get
really pumped and excited for it so just
the energy and the atmosphere for me is
10 times better
it's really important for all of us that
we are educated about line dancing we do
carry it on just because it is kind of a
lost art here in america
for me when i do have children one day i
would like to
pass that on to them as well i think
it's really important i think it's what
makes our family our family
[Music]
you